am 19 oktober 2017 wurde das erste
interstellare objekt überhaupt entdeckt
der dekan anders oma
das heißt so viel wie scout oder
nachrichten boote der erste boote aus
dem fernen welt alles wurde einst von
der internationalen astronomischen union
benannt das erste interstellare objekt
jetzt gibt es eine neue bahnbrechende
studie dazu wir haben darüber berichtet
und die legt nahe dass es sich um eine
alien sonder handelt wir haben exklusiv
den führenden autoren der studie
professor für astrophysik an der harvard
university und vorsitzender des
fachbereichs astronomie der harvard
university dazu interviewt kriegs und
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
seines videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen professor ist es richtig sie
als entdecker zu bezeichnen
nein ich glaube nicht wir haben nicht
genügend beweise um sich der
tatsächlichen natur und den ursprung
dieses objektes mit dem namen omar
sicher zu sein dass vor einem jahr
entdeckt wurde
aber es ist wie ein gast zum abendessen
zu haben bei dem sie erfahren dass er
aus einem anderen land ist und sie
können so etwas über dieses land
erfahren sie können etwas über seine
andere kultur lernen indem sie diesen
gast studieren ohne ein flugticket für
dieses land bezahlen zu müssen
das seltsame an diesem objekt ist dass
es eigenschaften vorweist die im
sonnensystem nicht existieren
es ist das erste objekt das von außen in
das sonnensystem eingedrungen ist aber
es ist sehr komisch es hat eine form die
viel extremer ist als jeder assault oder
komet den wir gesehen haben und wir
können das sagen weil es sonnenlicht
reflektiert und da das objekt nah an der
erde vorbei gekommen ist konnte
feststellen dass es sich alle acht
stunden dreht und dass sich die
helligkeit um etwa den faktor 10 ändert
was bedeutet dass es mindestens fünf mal
länger ist als breit wir wissen nicht
wie es aussieht weil wir keine
gelegenheit hatten ein bild aufzunehmen
es ist also so als hätten wir viele
leute zum abendessen gehabt und man
merkt leider erst danach dass einer von
ihnen am interessantesten war und du
hast keine chance bekommen mit dieser
person zu sprechen
wir haben also begrenzte daten aber alle
daten die wir
zeigen dass dieses ungewöhnlich ist
beispielsweise gibt es daten vom spitzer
weltraumteleskop die noch nicht
veröffentlicht wurden es gibt einige
berichte dass nicht viel hitze
wahrgenommen wurde
es gibt eine begrenzung wie waren dieses
objekt war
dieses bedeutet dass es sich um einen
sehr guten reflektor handelt und es kein
guter absorbiere des sonnenlichts ist
interessanterweise bewegt sich dieses
objekt jedoch in einer flugbahn die
nicht nur durch die schwerkraft der
sonne geformt wird
es wirkt eine zusätzliche kraft mit sehr
hoher bedeutung in der regel für kometen
kann die verdampfung von eis auf der
oberfläche des kometen einen
zusätzlichen schub geben
das ist was ihm den anschein eines
kometen gibt aber es gibt keinen kometen
schwanz bei diesem objekt und wenn es
vom kometen einen zusätzlichen schub gab
die ausgasung dann hätte diese ausgaben
durch die spinn periode des objekts
verändert und das konnten wir nicht
feststellen konnten wir nicht es muss
also eine andere quelle für diese kraft
geben es gibt zwei möglichkeiten
entweder ist diese analyse der daten
falsch sie wurde jedoch im nature
magazin von sehr angesehenen astronomen
berichtet entweder ist sie falsch hat
einen fehler oder es gibt eine andere
quelle für diese kraft und unser artikel
versuchte die zusätzliche quelle zu
erklären und wir schlugen vor dass das
sonnenlicht nur durch den
strahlungsdruck auf dieses objekt
einwirken konnte
damit dies effektiv ist muss das objekt
sehr dünn seien weniger als einen
millimeter dick und eine größe von etwa
20 metern haben oder mehr haben dass das
hört sich an wie ein segel wie ein licht
segel so wird es genannt ein segel das
durch licht er als durch wind
angetrieben wird wie die welche man auf
einem segelboot findet wie entwickelt
diese technologie derzeit für die
erforschung des weltraums
ich leite ein projekt namens star schott
ziel ist es das nächstgelegene
sternsystem alpha centauri zu besuchen
und ich werde auf der konferenz vor dem
wolf darüber sprechen
das hat mich dazu gefahr anlass die
möglichkeit in betracht zu ziehen dass
es vielleicht ein
ein lichtkegel ist und wenn ja wurde es
künstlich hergestellt und dann stellt
sich die frage wer hat das getan und ist
das eine fremde zivilisationen nun meine
herangehensweise an die frage sind wir
allein dies ist die grundlegende frage
in der wissenschaft weil sie unsere
perspektive auf unserem platz im
universum verändern würde
mein ansatz dazu ist dass wir so viele
daten wie möglich vom himmel sein müssen
ich spreche aus bescheidenheit ich denke
dass wir nicht besonders sind wie wir
wissen dass ein viertel aller sterne an
planeten wie die erde hat ungefähr so
groß wie die erde
mit der richtigen entfernung damit
flüssiges wasser an der oberfläche und
die chemie des lebens wie wir sie kennen
bestehen kann
und wenn man für ein viertel aller
sterne so und so oft würfelt milliarden
mal dann sehr wahrscheinlich dass es
primitives leben gibt mikroben aber
vielleicht auch intelligentes leben da
draußen und wir sollten nicht davon
ausgehen dass wir die antwort vor der
suche gehen
wir sollten aufgeschlossen sein ich
denke dass wir nichts besonderes sind
ich denke dass wir hier existieren ist
sehr wahrscheinlich dass es andere
zivilisationen gibt nun fragen sie
vielleicht warum haben wir noch keine
signale aber aus dem weltall auch warum
haben wir nichts gehört wo sind allem
wenn sie existieren eine möglichkeit ist
dass in kulturen die technologisch
fortgeschritten sind wie unsere eigene
in kurzer zeit ein explosiver prozess
stattfindet wir wissen dass es sechs
potenzielle die technologie entwickelt
sich exponentiell und zwar innerhalb von
jahren innerhalb weniger jahr hunde
hatten sie die mittel sich selbst zu
zerstören
ich meine wir sind schon dabei es ist
also durchaus möglich dass sie eine
kurze lebensdauer haben eine möglichkeit
dies herauszufinden besteht darin andere
planeten nach beweisen für ausgestorbene
zivilisationen zu durchsuchen
sie würden sehen ob ein planet ein
atomkrieg durchgemacht hat ein planet
der ein klima wandel erlebt hat das
könnte man erkennen oder wenn es
industrielle verschmutzung in der
atmosphäre haben gibt wenn wir beispiel
dafür finden würde uns das eine wichtige
lektion geben unsere handlungen
abzuwägen um sich besser zu benehmen um
unseren planeten zu erhalten damit wir
ein ähnliches schicksal für uns selbst
vermeiden also denken sie wir sind nicht
allein
ich denke aus bescheiden heißt es am
wahrscheinlichsten jeder der sagt dass
wir allein im universum sind ich denke
das zeigt arroganz wir wissen dass es
sehr natürlich ist meine töchter als sie
jung waren als sie klein waren dachten
sie dass sich die welt um sie herum
dreht aber als sie älter wurden reiften
sie und erkannten sie dass dies nicht
der fall war und ich denke wir als
zivilisation werden denselben weg gehen
anfangs dachten wir wir sind das zentrum
des physischen universums also dachten
wir es dass sich die sonne um die erde
bewegt und dann hören uns klar nein wir
sind nicht sie wissen schon
und dennoch denken viele wissenschaftler
und menschen dass wir in bezug auf das
leben etwas besonderes sind
im zentrum des biologischen universum
sind wir einzigartig ich glaube nicht
ich denke höchstwahrscheinlich aus
bescheidenheit dass es viele
erkenntnisse des lebens gibt die wir
hier an anderer stelle kennen mehr als
das schließt es auch sie zogen an
nun ist die frage wie wir sie finden
können und es ist eine praktische frage
wir müssen instrumente entwickeln mit
denen wir daten erhalten können weil die
wissenschaft oft beweisen beruht
dasselbe gilt für dieses objekt und die
art dieses objektes wird nicht durch
seine beliebtheit bei twitter bestimmt
und das relevant es ist was es ist und
wir brauchen nur informationen zu
sammeln und so wichtig ist zum beispiel
der beitrag den wir geschrieben haben es
wird die menschen dazu ermutigen das das
nächste mal wenn wir ein objekt sehen
dass aus dem interstellaren raum kommt
dass wir es mit den besten teleskopen
untersuchen werden die wir haben
damit wir alle informationen darüber
sammeln können und herausfinden was
seiner natur ist und natürlich müssen
humor und objekte dieser klasse in einer
umgebung produziert werden die sich vom
sonnensystem sehr unterscheidet den
prozess zu erlernen ist sehr ähnlich als
würde man zum strand und in die nähe des
ozeans gehen und muscheln betrachten die
an land gespült werden
und hin und wieder sieht man eine
plastikflasche von der wir annehmen
müssen dass die künstlichen ursprungs
ist das gleiche also sollte man hier
machen wir sollten jedes interstellarer
deck betrachten das in das sonnensystem
ein drückt und prüfen ob es natürlich
oder künstlich ist und es wird uns etwas
interessantes beibringen wenn wir also
annehmen dass wir nicht allein sind ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es sich um
ein künstliches objekt handelt das von
einer außerirdischen spezies gebaut
wurde wurde höher als die möglichkeit
dass es sich um ein natürliches objekt
handelt nein würde ich sagen eigentlich
wäre natürlich wahrscheinlicher aber vor
etwa zehn jahren schrieb ich einen
artikel in dem versucht wurde vorher zu
sagen wie viele asteroiden er natürlich
die gesteine das sonnensystem von außen
erreichen werden und wir haben das um
einen faktor von einer million bis zu
100 millionen geschätzt
irgendwo zwischen 100 und 100 millionen
weniger objekte als nötig den ursprung
von humor zu erklären
dieses objekt gehört also zu einer
klasse von objekten die weitaus größer
ist als wir auf grund von asteroiden im
sonnensystem erwartet hatten
die frage ist also wie kalt es selbst
wenn es natürlich ist wissen sie könnten
wir etwas neues über die umgebung lernen
in der es produziert wurde und ich denke
das wäre faszinieren
ich denke wir sollten aufgeschlossen
sein das ist mein grundlegender punkt
das ist das aber dein name sind dort
viele argumente dass es ein günstiges
objekt ist man muss verstehen dass
wissenschaft eine lernerfahrung ist
ist in arbeit es ist nicht wie in einem
lehrbuch sie geben ihnen die illusion
dass wissenschaft ein direkter weg ist
auf dem sie informationen sammeln und
schließlich zu einer schlussfolgerung
gelangen
nein es ist an dem prozess ist wie bei
kindern wenn sich fragen über die welt
stellen und an fehler machen und auch
von neugier getrieben werden dasselbe
gilt für wissenschaft wenn wir versuchen
so viele beweise wie möglich zu sammeln
während des prozesses machen wir fehler
wir sind uns oft nicht sicher oft haben
wir unterschiedliche meinungen über die
interpretation einiger daten und deren
lernprozesse und die öffentlichkeit muss
das verstehen weil es kein sauberer
prozess ist während der untersuchung
werden sie unvollständige daten haben
manchmal ist die analyse falsch manchmal
ist die interpretation falscher es ist
ein prozess und wenn menschen erkennen
dass es sich um einen prozess handelt
bekommen wissenschaftler mehr
glaubwürdigkeit denn einerseits kann man
sagen dass mit dem klimawandel eine
riesige menge an daten vorliegt die
unsere interpretation unterstützen und
wir sind ziemlich zuversichtlich dass
wir etwas tun dass die umwelt
beeinflusst
in anderen teilen der wissenschaft haben
wie dem bereich in dem wir nicht
genügend daten haben wir noch lernen
müssen es ist nicht so als ob alles
gleich ist wir müssen jedes thema nach
seinem eigenen wert betragen
ok es scheint als hätten sie viele
gründe warum es eine million sonde sein
könnte aber sie wollen es sich sagen
weil es immer noch ungewöhnlich ist nein
ich würde sagen es ist eine möglichkeit
die auf dem tisch sein sollte und ich
würde es als eine realistische
möglichkeit neben einem natürlichen
ursprung betrachten
aber sie haben keine erklärung für den
natürlichen ursprung ich habe keine
erklärung für diesen zusätzlichen schub
es gibt eine gute maxime von sherlock
holmes der detektiv der sagte wenn man
das unmögliche ausgeschlossen hat muss
das was übrig bleibt die waadt sein so
unwahrscheinlich sie auch klingen mag
und so sollten wir der wissenschaft
vorgehen wir sollten keine vorurteile
haben und er stimme dem völlig zu aber
ich glaube nicht
das wird zu diesem gegenstand genügend
informationen nahmen um sicher zu sein
ich hätte gerne ein bild das wäre
wunderbar das nächste mal wenn es ein
objekt gibt könnten wir die besten
teleskope verwenden um es anzusehen
wir könnten auch über eine mission
nachdenken die einen besseren überblick
bietet aber aber war es nicht so schnell
davon
nein denn wenn sie es früh genug
erspähen können sie es einfangen wer
sich uns nährt und dann ist es leicht
ist zu erreichen
die frage ist also in welchem teil des
ortes ihn anfang jetzt fällt es eltern
ist es schwierig wir können es nicht mit
unseren raketen erreichen aber innerhalb
von ein oder zwei jahrzehnten entwickeln
wir möglicherweise technologien mit
denen wir schneller vorankommen können
mit dem betrieb zum beispiel nein wir
müssen uns nur zehn mal schnell bewegen
als der chemische antrieb dann ist es
möglich dass wir dorthin gelangen
könnten
und den könnten wir eigentlich auch in
einem jahrzehnt noch nachgehen da das
objekt tausende von jahren braucht um
durch das sonnensystem zu reisen mit dem
break star show project planen sie eine
geschwindigkeit von 20 prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit
aber dieses objekt war langsamer dieses
objekt bewegt sich mit einem prozent
eines prozent der lichtgeschwindigkeit
also zehn hoch minus 4 sehr langsam
so können wir es leicht erfassen mit
einem fünftel der lichtgeschwindigkeit
erreichen sie den pluto innerhalb
weniger tage
neuneinhalb jahre dauert es bis new
horizon zum pluto kam und das ist
ungefähr die zeit die dieses objekt
braucht um dorthin zu zehn jahre oder so
für uns können wir in wenigen tagen mit
einem fünftel ehrlich geschwindigkeit
dorthin gelangen
also nichts leichter als das es wäre
leicht dieses objekt einzuholen wenn wir
die technologie eines fünftels der
lichtgeschwindigkeit hätten aber wir
haben sie noch nicht wenn wir die in den
nächsten jahrzehnten entwickeln müssen
wir uns nicht sehr beeilen denn sobald
wir die haben da können wir dieses
objekt leicht an
für eine sonde wie die break zu starker
sonne werden subjekt jedoch eine sehr
langsame songs wie stimmt nun fragen sie
vielleicht ob sich andere sondern sehr
schnell bewegen könnten
und die antwort ist ja
es wäre schwieriger für uns sie zu
bemerken weil sie vor allem sehr klein
sein könnten
wir planen also etwas sehr kleines zu
schicken wenn sie klein sind
reflektieren sie sehr wenig sonnenlicht
sie bewegen sich auch extrem schnell so
dass sie von astronomen nicht
wahrgenommen werden können die
astronomen nicht darauf eingestellt
werden dass ich etwas so schnell über
den himmel bewegen kann und so klein ist
und ich denke wir würden es verpassen es
ist also durchaus möglich dass sich raum
fahrzeuge bewegen wir bemerken sie nicht
ich hoffe also wenn wir die technologie
entwickeln um das sonnensystem zu
verlassen werden wir beim verlassen die
meldung willkommen im interstellaren
club erhalten
es würde viel verkehr da draußen geben
den wir vorher nicht bemerkt haben und
ich werde und ich wäre nicht überrascht
wir neigen zu der annahme dass die
beweise für das leben auf einem planeten
neben einem stern zu finden werden aber
es ist durchaus möglich dass die signale
auf raumfahrzeugen die sich durch den
interstellaren raum bewegen leichter zu
finden sind
irgendwann werden wir eine nachricht in
einer flasche finden anstatt durch ein
signal nach einer nachricht zu suchen
und vielleicht war um humor so einer
das ist also aufregend und warum sollte
das allererste objekt das durch den
interstellaren raum kommt so
ungewöhnlich sein
es kann kein ausreißer sein oder
denn das erste was man sieht sollte
typisch seien ja ich denke man fürchtet
zu sagen dass es von einer
außerirdischen spezies sein könnte mal
niemand das vermutlich helfen richtig
wir sollten nicht voreingenommen seien
wir sollten ein natürliches und ein
günstiges objekt als eine möglichkeit
betrachten und dann beachten sie die
beweise um zu entscheiden was es ist
aber im fall von humor ist es natürlich
auch ungewöhnlich wenn es natürlich ist
es ist keine art von asteroiden die
einfach so aus dem sonnensystem
geschleudert werden und die fülle
zufällige objekte die sie benötigen um
sie zu erklären ist viel größer als wir
erwartet hätten
daher ist es in jeder hinsicht etwas
neues und wir sollten mehr darüber
erfahren und der weg mehr zu lernen ist
nicht darüber zu twittern und in den
sozialen medien darüber zu sprechen
ich interessiere mich nicht wirklich für
die spannung um die es den menschen geht
sie wissen dass kaleo sagte die
gebildete meinung einer person ist
wichtiger als das robert tausend
menschen sprechen die über weniger
informationen verfügen
und er sprach hauptsächlich über das
wissen dass er über die erde hatte die
sich um die sonne bewegte und nicht über
die sonne die sich um die erde bewegt
und die kirche stellte ihn unter
hausarrest
denn die kirche war die dominierende
soziale macht und es wirklich irrelevant
wie viele leute das falsche sagen was
sie brauchen sind beweise und daten
ich hoffe dass wir in zukunft mehr über
humor oder über gegenstände aus seiner
klasse erfahren werden und dann werden
wir hoffentlich mehr wissen
[Musik]
wenn ihr keinen video dazu verpassen
wollt dann abonniert am besten auch den
englischen kanal einfach hier
draufklicken von klicks und da gibt es
auch die ein oder andere video premiere
wie zum beispiel dieses interview das
hatten wir dazu erst glocke natürlich
nicht vergessen und darunter geht es
weiter mit
die end of the universe stay tuned
einziehen